big welcome to you all Martin Tyler here
Alan Smith sitting alongside me we to
enjoy this particular style of the game
in the survival mode you know one of
those that you can't take your eyes off
really always entertaining and always a
balanced affair because of the format
everybody knows the Ben ABEO Stadium
here in Madrid Alan but perhaps not why
it's called Santiago bernabéu was a when
a man of all parts for the club a real
one club man played retro football coach
manager president yeah not many
associated more closely with his
Football Club than old Santiago from
1911 to 1978 quite incredible ESMA
but rich and here's the shot
[Applause]
[Music]
most managers approach to this game
[Applause]
no that part from the holidays and he
scored that distance it's an incredible
story
[Music]
Wow look at the manager he works hard on
his team on the training ground and seen
some reward for it down there no so a
pile will be removed now that they've
got the gold real madrid had to lead
Miranda
trying to shred a pass through but not
successful
well
striving for a chance the balls loose
coke even made the save but he couldn't
hold it he's got that well out of harm's
way
Gareth Bale modrich it could lay it off
to the supporting player
casimiro don't impart rich veil
and he start around Madrid
brilliant football
from her suitor table struck twice as
many minutes
it wasn't an individual goal it was a
beautiful team effort
lovely interplay
[Music]
[Applause]
it's really interesting now with a
number of players off and the latest
because of that goal restarting a tuna
vecino Antonia can driver
routine for the keeper trying to catch
the player in possession fail
[Applause]
aim for Karim Benzema oh it's off the
bar
[Applause]
it's it.well just needed a bit more luck
without effort
good place to win the ball here
[Applause]
don't for the poor break quickly when
they get possession depending team has
done well to reposition but they haven't
got the ball and here we've got a
free-kick given by the referee
undoubtedly a free-kick and I think some
would say that should be a booking but
this referee doesn't see it that way
no he doesn't think you got take Tom the
shot is one of those special moments you
don't often see a glorious goal
[Applause]
well they were caught out here by this
quick counter-attack against the run of
play yeah I mean they had to stick
together there and come under a lot of
pressure but with the place in the team
that was always likely
[Applause]
so there's the goal and we'll see the
player going off now and we restart the
game 2-1
probing paths they take you on the
defenders and here's the shot they
defend this Benzema
[Applause]
after this it should get them across the
[ __ ]
you have to be there to score it ran
thought this was a coach's effort the
final finish was difficult but to get
there took a little bit of instinct
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm sure you got the hang of it now
that's a goal and a player removed and
maybe more room for the other team 3 1
the score line as we restart the game
vicino ratchet 9 :
a Samoa
he's got his tackle in and the Paul's
gone out down a Samoa ratchet 9 gullet
it's gonna shut up now
[Applause]
ben's of are very clever play some like
him really to play the ball straight to
the opposition
[Applause]
that's a great interception threading it
through
[Applause]
still a charts in there of the
goalkeeper
night go that they blocked it that
could be closed town here
[Applause]
failed sloppy Paris itch and I'd go that
trying a bit too hard trying to force
the pass and it went straight to an
opponent
[Applause]
they see no
Pera such as a fine challenge and he's
got the ball it's back within two
[Applause]
Asamoah vecino that's a half time now
and the score is free walk in to kick
off the second half
Parris H
not go loud
gotta pass the ball a bit better than
this if they're going to make progress
couldn't it straight away simple save
from an ambitious effort
[Applause]
Benzema
really trying to use the full width of
the pitch here to make some progress
Paris itch got the ball and they're
going at the opposition with speed
trying to slip it through real chance
can't Drava try to find the winning
ticket in the report but the numbers
short yes he took it early though
pressed hi here
and the referee says free-kick
well long overdue you feel this James
resides us behind a switch of tactics
now here's casimiro I came to help the
mid feel this Benzema here
[Applause]
Bacardi intercepted well
look Ahmad rich making his move forward
and it's been an hour of very good
football here we've still got 30 moment
a free-kick
awarded by the referee
coming up is a switch in personnel for
Real Madrid
superb shimmy then when you want a
player to beat a defender in a
one-on-one he's that boy mod rich
[Applause]
they can be looking for a through ball
and on the goalkeeper
to the rescue and how goalkeeper on his
toes off his line and he can kick it
away and Rover
you could see what he was trying to do
with the cross but it's a gold King
well that tackle what did you think Aled
it was a beauty timed it perfectly Perry
siege
well that's straightforward for the
goalkeeper
it's going to be a throw-in after that
tackle mod rich
Ceballos
maybe intercept it
[Applause]
moderate
and then he goes with the tackle
slipping it through
[Applause]
Roderich fail
[Applause]
could work really to read the intention
of the pass
[Applause]
Meritage
it's a good cross put away but not a
goal for enter
well they're on the comeback trail Alan
yeah I can smell something in the air
here I think they can because they look
the team on the up now another angle on
it here
[Applause]
it's really interesting now with a
number of players off and their latest
because of that goal very good game 3-2
and we have 9 remaining minutes
[Applause]
Bale trying to ball in behind throw
everything behind that shot and
frustrated that it wasn't quite on
target well if he keeps getting he knows
kind of areas I'm sure he'll score
pretty soon
[Applause]
ah Samoa
well he has cleared the danger if he saw
the look from the other player and saw
where the pass was going and read it not
long now for Real Madrid yet the fans
fully expecting to go home with the win
here trying to switch on the attacking
power in this situation good strong
tackle shut up everybody be up for the
corner for the equalizing chance
[Applause]
can drovers corner this might be an
opportunity to get level goalkeeper out
of position and from close range he
really should have scored they should
that was a golden opportunity spurned
now nacho
[Applause]
Parris H
and it's a win here as the final whistle
goes for Real Madrid I've been quite
impressed with them today and what about
you they've got a win they have got a
win